they were sent home by Bachelorette
Jojo Fletcher in shocking exits Monday
night it's not supposed to happen and it
is I jumped over a hurdle that I've
never done before and now I'm skewered
now after a little prodding Luke fell
and chase McNary both tell me they are
in talks to be the next Bachelor is that
something you would do is it something
that's being discussed you know that's I
guess don't lie to me change the
discussions are there but it's just I
don't know it's there's a lot of weight
there a lot of people want you to be the
next Bachelor is that something that's
in discussion would you do that I'm at a
place now where it feels good to be in
love and and I would definitely look
forward to that in the future Luke
you're not really answering my question
it's a possibility and so I definitely I
definitely would not pass on it so while
Luke is totally in Chase has some
reservations you're putting the
microscope of America and that's scary
well who do you want to see be the next
Bachelor Luke Chase or someone else
entirely let me know on Twitter I'm at
Lauren Zuma